[Music]
in ruining my life news yeah mom
submitted by wafers are not cookies
agree tap that fist you know what it's
up you see right you go excuse me
you're welcome back anytime bones
they're not good so they're not cookies
good to you then I'm gonna judge you now
what is it these cookies these these
damn delicious cookies it's all very
delicious wafers are good they're just
not cooked they're not cooking I don't
think they're good and you see her
opinion in this group it is uh invalid
it's very valid doesn't even count she
doesn't even eat him how she gonna know
yep she hates him they have that
plasticy cream-filled what am i like
Oreos though I have no time I do like
wafers but they're not cookies they are
cookies wafer No Oreos a cookie we first
are closer to a cake than anything okay
cookie wafer you see this that's the
crazy should not sell it has layers it's
that's that's more real
so do orient all right so when you look
at that tree of evolution with all of
the different animals right and then you
look at the [ __ ] relatives of a
cookie in a way for ya it doesn't matter
does it
in screenshots of package or photos of
pack they don't know English though oh
yeah might a crazy be quiet
I don't know English yeah do they speak
American English it might be from like
Australia because you know how they call
cookies biscuits oh that's right they
don't know you smart they call fries
champion yeah girl from Australia a
while ago and I had a role it was that
big con I had a role and I was like odd
these roles aren't very good she's like
you call that a role and I'm just like I
don't know I was like yeah what do you
call and she was like we don't have
those and I was like what do you mean
you don't have buns like they got some
weird bread situation they don't have
but like a pepper blind Shawn was like
what do you call this and she was like I
don't know we don't have those and I was
like what do they call dinner rolls
that's what I was I was like this is a
roll
well that a thing on Twitter recently
where there was like a debate on what
people actually call those I don't know
what it's wrong give me like a cinnamon
roll like I'm like a mine like a dinner
roll all I got dinner she was like we
don't have those and I was like why the
[ __ ] do they eat koala feet
dude [ __ ] koala feet eat mashed
[ __ ] astronaut legend Buzz
Aldrin says his greedy kids are
sabotaging his love life to retain
control over his money [ __ ] [ __ ]
oh that was still alive who the [ __ ] is
Buzz Aldrin what he's the one that faked
the moon landing yeah apparently I don't
know if all the og astronauts are dead
nah dude how do you think Buzz Lightyear
thought his name yeah I know I thought
they're trying to pay homage to the og
see I heard a buck alter his name I just
don't know what his relevance is to a
space stuff he was a sorry not the first
who's the second person to walk on the
road okay
the first is Neil Armstrong oh okay I
know who Neil Armstrong is yeah he's a
the other moon boy okay so here's the
silver medal this rock was an Olympian
that's Lance wait no that's Lance
Armstrong is a biker it wasn't alright
88 years old yeah he survived and he
said that his son and his daughter so
his son is 60 and his daughters 51 have
been committing fraud by claiming that
he has health problems and they're just
trying to seize control of his you raise
some [ __ ] [ __ ] what think about this
he's 88 right what kind of brizl wants
to get with him she wants money
breezy Oh Brazil the bristles yeah yeah
I got it
well what if there was like a 75 year
old that was like truly in love or like
he's got so many groupies though like
what
appreciate what's the percent like it
might be a bristle that just wants his
dough and his kids could be trying to
protect him does David skin routine good
looks like Tywin Lannister he's got a
tie and a bowtie he's double [ __ ] do
it what if his kids are just trying to
help him but he is like his mind is just
all like a monkey but look good I'm his
daughter looks old and this is his son
his son oh my god his friend like a
seimei's oh my god he's such a papa good
genes not really cuz it's kids look like
[ __ ] you got a balding and [ __ ] when he
was young duffle looks powerful I know
yeah [ __ ] how do you be 88 it's still
alive like that I heard you gotta be a
bad I mean vibrant in a lie no but he
looks like he looks like a power that's
crazy he look he looked like [ __ ] back
in the day but now he looks good for his
age yeah it's all that anti-gravity I
want to be in anti-gravity so we could
decompress my spine alright and it makes
you taller oh yeah I come back down big
there also lose all muscle mass - she'll
be up there he doesn't he's almost there
we talking about I got this little baby
bump no but the thing that his son has
swiped nearly half a million dollars
from his personal bank account in the
past two years how did he do that I
don't hang his bills his dad's bills I
know it'd be so funny and then
they have both of his kids have swiped
space memorabilia and have blocked him
from having any relationships with MIT
with women so they can control his money
oh well then maybe they're just like dad
you got a [ __ ] problem man and you keep
[ __ ] burning money with all these
girls and [ __ ] how I gotta say you could
be with these [ __ ] Astro groupies
yeah man
and ancient aliens is really hot right
now so you know there's a whole new
[ __ ] young fan base I wonder if like
astronauts have play astronaut sex jokes
when they have sex issue oh yeah that'd
be [ __ ] hilarious dude tell me one
suck on my asteroids or some [ __ ] like
that
oh I think he likes it oh god not again
buzz about to [ __ ] enter that
satellite even one two three blast-off
[Laughter]
yeah about to fix that satellite
reception you're good because I know I'm
all sitting over here trying to think of
why I like trying to come in like
looking no double-dutch in there huh
yeah just some space words and then try
to save it go I want to type it to the
Uranus yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
[ __ ] moon landing hold it show me
that NASA MST very good this is green I
know so nasty NASA TV anyway yes so now
he's suing his kids oh [ __ ] this is real
it'd be really funny if he's just like
suffering from dementia yeah at first I
was like he looks real good then when
y'all put it out the bowtie and the kids
are saying that he suffers from dementia
and Alzheimer's that says buzz is saying
that they're lying because they just
want to control his money there is it
there is an episode of Law & Order like
this and I don't know what to believe
straight up because I painted that
episode I still don't know what the
bleep it might be a little hard for me
to believe that just because he's quite
an intelligent human being and usually
people who constantly use their brains
don't I mean if they have a family
history of like dementia and maybe the
Wall Street Journal was interviewing a
longtime friend of his and he said that
quote was of the genius he's the
smartest guy I've ever met the buzz has
never been straight smart so apparently
he's saying that he's not great with
money okay okay okay so probably China
point has a [ __ ] problem mm-hmm I knew
it trying to give it up like oh yeah
the kids they said that we are deeply
disappointed and saddened by the
unjustified lawsuit that has been
brought against us we love and respect
our Father very much and remain hopeful
that we can rise above the situation and
recover the strong relationship that
built this foundation in the first thing
I hate when people write stuff like that
it's like that sure pops like why would
you I hate these formal stuff you know I
mean it's like well how about I wrote
like yeah what the [ __ ] you know yeah
dad and that's the statement yeah yeah
that's [ __ ] weird us your father you
talk like that that's looking I don't
like that makes me question their
integrity exactly I'm talking to of a
dad yeah but still that's not the right
yeah if the media came to me if the
media came to me I've got a look
[ __ ] my mom is [ __ ] crazy I'm
trying to protect this [ __ ] right now
you know what [ __ ] happened she's
been through like five divorces and
[ __ ] every time this [ __ ]
takes all her money now she's not gonna
have
anything left for me what the [ __ ] is
going on she dad boxes the chocolate
today real family language you can't so
because now he's suited up and lowered
up and then if the the family makes are
the kids make it yeah but can't even be
in that it's Family Affairs what are you
talking about this is a public statement
I know what their [ __ ] up ready what
are you talking about what never sue my
parents they're not suing their parents
a train suing them I know but I think
there's would be no loss to do it would
be no lawyer in between my family should
I know but if the dad is kind of losing
his [ __ ] mark so if he's losing his
mommy's bring the lawyer the kids either
son straily
look at your [ __ ] crazy right but
what if the lawyer is so money hungry
that he's getting in between all of that
he's luring up Brandon lawyer you know
this scarlet letter on the forehead
right so I think that's why they're
probably doing it like that's that they
can communicate with the dead and then
the lawyers like all what are they to
say definitely she don't worry some of
the lawyer lawyers it's all the lawyers
Paul I feel like they wouldn't have like
a medical professional coming to be like
oh yeah he lost it he ain't yeah you
know he took so much viagra his brain is
gone
goodbye or does that I mean I don't know
the blood goes to the dick and out of
the brain yeah losing oxygen and blood
pressure when you guys are curious he
has been married three times that's all
bad that's 488 that's not bad it sounds
about right
maybe he outlived his wives if they died
then it's different
let me see a lot of geniuses and higher
achievers they it's hard from the whole
long term marriage oh I'm glad I'm doing
cuz I looked up Elon Musk's also
inspired by them and you have five
divorces already yeah any so yeah forty
you know he has five see for me that's
so dumb it's like just be single you
don't have to be in a committed
relationship but people need that they
need the stability then you could just
you're rich just pay for it some people
are like a real managua I don't want
that he wasn't a widower no cuz if
you're like so high achieving like Elon
Musk
like obviously you put work first
exactly everything then like why do you
get married cuz you need that stability
and even love you need to rock
yeah then if you're gonna hold on to the
rock why would you throw the rock away
five times exactly
alright I was counter to they know what
you want easier said than that it is
easier said than done so we can't sit
here and say [ __ ] like we got a perfect
relationship I say it because I say
whatever I want
true he was gonna say cuz I do have a
perfect one I said because I ignore all
the fact why marriage is crumbling right
relationship because I can say whatever
I want
[Music]